now the upcoming series of the crown has
come under intense criticism due to its
betrayal of the royal family Dame Judy
Dench has called for a disclaimer to be
added to the show for the sake of a
family and a nation so recently bereaved
and former prime minister John Major has
dismissed the series as a barrel load of
malicious nonsense
in light of the events of the last 12
months
perhaps I have more to reflect on than
most
[Music]
Royal scandals damaged the country's
reputation
it won't go quietly I'll battle till the
end
how did it come
to still Weathers in the studio is the
times political sketchwriter Quentin
Letts and a warm welcome to historical
novelist I'm a fan girl Philippa Gregory
Quentin do you think it's a bit soon
after the death of her majesty for
Netflix to be screening something as
sensitive as this uh basically Nadine
I'm a Live and Let Live person and I
also dislike any sort of constraint on
freedom of speech but that shouldn't
stop us saying that
um this is the behavior of uh malicious
scavengers uh and that Netflix or at
least the the crown people are behaving
like
um like vultures but they are we should
see them not as vultures perhaps we
should see them as as ticks or fleas on
the hide of The Magnificent Leviathan uh
a great Sleek bear that is the royal
family or is that it is monarchy and so
you know they're they're a small uh TV
outfit who watches Netflix and um I
think you know just let them have their
bit of my their little minor bit of
drama and it is a drama it is a drama
yeah but what about the boys no Prince
William's side well that's where you get
it today was the hardest day of his life
this is where you get into what a former
um there's a man called lord McGregor
who is in charge of press complaints and
he talked once about dabbling in
people's souls and this is where you get
into slightly difficult Waters because
yes this is a fiction and you know
fiction has uh a very important part to
play in our lives and in our art and our
culture but at the same time it's
fiction based on drama and it's so
recent that that's where you start
trading into these slightly sort of what
about disclaimer Quentin you know this
England with Kenneth Branagh had a
disclaimer on the front that said at the
beginning of every episode this is
fiction well does that I mean remember
to put it on the trail and on the actual
program on the episodes do you know what
why would they put it on the trailer why
wouldn't they put it on the episodes
that air well I think you probably have
to be a bit stupid if you don't
understand the crown is
I don't know perhaps they should also
have a disclaimer saying that we you
know we Netflix employee Prince Harry so
how could he possibly be upset about
this uh you know well they don't
actually employ them do they well they
give him loot well he's made they're
making a document quite a lot they're
not actually employing them but do you
not think this are involved in the
making of that program but there is
there is a build up of pressure for
Netflix to put a disclaimer on the front
do you think they should bow to that
pressure will they bow to pressure first
from Sir John Major I think they might
possibly might ignore him
um and they have they have put it on the
trailer already so we could see we could
see movements I think I think this is a
this is a hoo-ha and we enjoyed getting
upset about it and it is a bit unseemly
it's unsporting it's unkind but it's
it's
apart I've read all your novels so um
but do you think that it's wrong that
the royal family don't I mean you write
about an amazing not about Elizabeth the
first but this the royal family today
they don't have a right of reply it's
not a historical documentary it's very
much involving members of the royal
family you're alive today do you think
it's wrong that they don't have the
right to reply of course they have the
right to reply they just have to speak
up nobody's stopping them speaking out
when they want to speak out they do when
they want to sue people they do they
have every right to reply but this isn't
a factual account that they can sue for
libel over though I would imagine that
depending on how close Netflix gets the
win there might be things that would
look up
planets but nobody thinks it's real I
mean if you show me one person who
thinks this is history then we'll have a
completely different discussion because
what we're doing
I think this is how a lot of people do
you know loyal family and I think that's
a credit to the writers Well everybody's
actually complaining about the fact that
it doesn't carry a disclaimer
is it close to the Bone but people are
complaining about the fact that it
doesn't have a disclaimer are the people
who don't want the story told and the
way that the journalists at the
dramatists are telling it it's not that
they're complaining that it's about real
people it's that they're complaining
that they think other people not their
intelligent literate well-read selves
are getting the wrong end of the stick
and this is just a usual thing about
stupid people out there are doing stupid
things and I should set them right so
Philippa is it close to the Bone do you
think it's closer to the truth than
perhaps those who people who are
complaining don't realize well since the
Freedom of Information Act doesn't cover
the Royal palaces there's no historian
that can check it out the fact checking
that's been private lives how can it be
checked out because they're monarchs
because they're Royal but they're dive
at people their individuals have a right
to privacy and to not have that their
private lives televised or made into
factional documentaries which Veer very
far from the truth nobody has that right
I know we all have that right but can we
really argue that about them I mean no
we're talking about some of the most
famous people about their famous people
in the world and what we're arguing now
is whether it is a painful thing for the
two brothers who lost who lost their
mother but that is 25 years
they don't have to watch it if they
don't want you have edited a big
newspaper and you know that there are
it's not necessarily written down in law
sometimes what what one can write about
it's to do with uh what where the
acceptable bands are on the sport of it
and Netflix do they trade in they trade
in a slightly dodgy way on this and that
they try to do present this by making it
so such a facsimile of and making the
characters so lifelike making them all
sound like the real members of the royal
family they are trading on on slightly
half truths there and the real truth in
this the truth the truth is not to do
who said what when and where it's to do
with uh aspects of character and I think
that the great truths in life are based
on character and we know what the
character of the queen was we know what
the character of King Charles is and I
think that the public will see through
that and the the audiences will
establish a truth of their own I mean I
I I'm my actual personal opinion is the
crown has done a normal of good for the
royal family and including King Charles
actually because I think the portrayal
of him as a young man was very
sympathetic and we saw elements of him
that maybe made us think when he feels a
bit wooden or when we saw him at his
accession there was a moment when he got
a little bit angry and a bit testy that
there's that that childhood scene when
he sent off to Gordon Stern and his
mother turning away from him I think it
made us realize what some of the sort of
pressure of growing up in that in that
family was so maybe the argument is the
royal family can't can't have it both
that's good for the Royal firm in in
America Quentin Philippa thank you so
much two sports have just stop oil have
covered Madame Tussaud's Wax work model
of King Charles III with chocolate cake
today the climate activists are
demanding the government halts all new
oil and gas licenses and consents Nadine
what do you make of this well the
tarquins and the others were in central
Lobby in Westminster today up to similar
antics
you know it's it's an Indulgence you
know we've been staying for a long time
we have to stop this they disrupt
everybody's lives they stop ambulances
getting to hospitals they stop people
getting to work they stop children
getting to school they they deface
statues and and monuments they just have
to stop it's totally unacceptable
oh well cop26 was the most successful
conference there has been held ever in
the years
and are you continuing with the cop 26
resolution yes
they've always had a brilliant PR effort